on n'attend pas 40 ans pour dire
monsieur polanski m'a mis la main au cra
de la servir alors là elle alors
je te dit la phrase et puis après tu
pourras l'aïr d'accord on le dénonce
tout de suite on attend par 40 ans peau
d un monsieur polanski n'a mis la main
au cul c'est ce qui m'agace dans le
mouvement mis tout comme si toutes ces
actrices découvrait tardivement les
choses on a le choix dans nos existences
on n'est pas obligé de tout accepter on
peut dire non et puis c'est tout elle
avait même été combien de chambres
d'hôtel pour officiellement parler d'un
rôle est donc elle a raconté son
expérience voilà ça n'a pas donné suite
pourquoi tu la bible en fait c'est
horrible c'est une femme qui le dit sur
wii nommé l a pas été la seule vous
savez toutes les femmes un petit peu old
school catherine deneuve avait aussi dit
qu'une petite main au cul de temps en
temps c'était pas si désagréable toutes
les femmes dans notre temps dans l'autre
monde d'une autre vie en fait tu trouves
que ce qu'ils étaient avant de
normalement aujourd'hui ça devrait
passer encore maintenant chers mandat
lire ce que je vomis en fait les
victimes qui se sentent déjà pas bien
quand elle dit oui on n'a pas besoin
d'attendre 44-40 on ne sait pas quoi
elle les fait se sentir encore plus mal
qu'elle ne se soit pas fait la main de
même si c'est ce que l'on dit de venir
ici
alors dis-moi ce qu'elle dit mais
regarde pareil il a par dont j'aime un
totem beaucoup je m'adresse fin mai
calamiteux de l'âge
avec vous n'êtes pas loin chéri
on
va toujours trop loin excuse moi
isabelle mais non terence adorait sa
rondeur non après amanda lear à 92 ans
me dénarié cia tant pis et 10 37 alors
on a bien effectivement vingt ans
d'écart avec césar alors dit
dis moi c'est les litiges et d'être un
autre temps moi je connais des jeunes
femmes qui emmène entre 20 et 30 ans qui
pense rigoureusement la même chose
porter il faut arrêter de catégoriser
absolument tout et c'est vrai que je
n'ai de ménage qui n'a pas 80 ans a été
l'une des premières à dire y'a aucun
contrat qui ne justifie qu'on monte dans
la chambre d'un paysage voilà bah moi je
sais quoi est une maniaque moi n'y a que
ça qui me choque tout le reste me choque
pas rien ne me choque je suis à 100
d'air toutes ces femmes qui
effectivement ne pouvait pas sur le
moment se plaindre yaka truc que je
trouve étonnant c'est que tu sois garçon
fils ça peut arriver sur des gains mais
bien sûr si oui mais quand quant à
producteurs te dis viens dans ma chambre
à minuit et demi dans ma chambre d'hôtel
vous parlez d'un contrat donc voilà
c'est l'univers de bureaux dans le
septième art aussi donc des fois les
gens peuvent y aller de façon telle
issue et moi je pense que c'est pas ça
qui est le dire entre autres elle dit
aussi autre chose elle dit c'est bizarre
et always on va faire ppda des gens qui
attendent 15 ans ou 20 ans pour dire moi
aussi ça m'est arrivé oui c'est ça qui
est pourquoi que je n'ai pas d'idée en
force du groupe c'est à dire ils sont là
bien sûr à savoir je pense alors parole
ouvert pense comme dans les autres se
met à suivre
avec parfois des extraits parce que la
notion d'entreprise est une notion très
important oui maintenant temps c'est à
certaines personnes qui vont dans la
brèche moi je comprends que je ne sois
pas le premier à parler
des jeux persuadé que l'ue peut
l'interdire aux mineurs mais je suis
persuadé que c'est pas la première fois
qu'elle se mette une main dans les
fesses amanda lear sur les ponts sur les
faits
cécile fs voiture neuve ou sur roue d'or
non mes potes dans le mécénat mais jean
claude
allègre a voulu marquer le coup comme
quoi en garde mathieu elle a été elle a
été comme quoi c'était roman polanski a
la boule visière ou l'envol ans t'es pas
c'est pas autre chose mais c'est sûr
condamné dû lui mettre tenait au fait
pourquoi jean mon avis
les mains dans les faits ce nouvel
guillermic pana cup est maintenant mais
c'est une grande force et un autre à
tort tout le monde à sainte-anne jean
thomas grimm entre les femmes qui se
plaignent à l'époque elle savait très
bien que faisait quelque chose qui était
pas bien c'est un échange de
noms dont des pas me tuer si honte et la
phobie de doute elle a profité on la
prie pâle profiter le savez ce n'est pas
énorme j'avais pas trop
mal et si l'on peut laisser dire ça
c'est pas vrai les femmes sont victimes
mr ça continue et d'un vote on met la
main sur toi et que tu ne veux pas tu es
victime de qu'elle ne trouvait pas mais
je dis qu'un paquet de gens qui ne
veulent pas à ben woodside hamas à dubaï
alors débat dans le même sac c'est à
dire que je pense qu'il ya sur les
dizaines de victimes des femmes qui en
effet sont vraiment victime à huy et
d'autres qui peut être aussi essais se
font construire amanda lear heures sur
laval font dévisser licence d'agencé
profit du système c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut envisager on peut pas mettre
tout le monde dans le même sac tu avais
rien quand même aussi le droit de dire
qu à titre personnel jamais de la vie
quand bien même on m'a vite dans une
chambre d'hôtel pour un film qui sera
présenté au festival de cannes je ne
rentrerai dans cette chambre 8 merga du
son excusez moi j'ai rien à tout faire
joli mais qui les attend quelle belle
chance
quand nous dire sur ppda par exemple
beaucoup de gens moi j'ai connu comme
nous tous plein de journalistes
féminines qui ont bossé avec moi à
l'époque et qui me racontait des phrases
que le beller exactement ce qu'on
l'entend enfermement dans le bureau à
neige je me des sables de vente c'est un
moment donné on peut dire à ces finales
et pas dans le bureau de m'aider à
partir de 20h30 à 22h quand vous savez
que ça va se passer comme ça elle y
allait parce que c'était compliqué mais
c'est pas pareil lors c'est pas pareil
il aura pas une chambre d'hôtel ballon
sous chambre d'hôtel à 23h à connotation
la tétine livré que notation comme elle
une chambre d'hôtel à tous et très bien
et est allé sur plein de festivals
cannes machin etc raconté à cannes tu
fasses congénères wilquin pour un
producteur etc quand tu rentres qui
l'encré noire qui leur ont peiné comme
ça avec une coupe de cheveux bien que de
la beauce et
rappelle à quelques années il apparaît
père du festival de cannes je me
rappelle il ya quelques années de ça
alors qu'il y avait certaines femmes qui
se mettaient carrément à poil mais
réellement dans la rue pour se faire
remarquer non mais tu
sais pas mais starlet c'est pareil
saragosse et pas les starlettes s'est
séparé
sont changés les fire dance ont changé
je pense qu'effectivement yade au cas
par cas mais prêter attention à ce qu'on
dit que non mais j'ai rien dit de
d'exception contre ppda certaines amies
et tout le monde me disait à l'époque
mais toi tu es méchante voilà donc
dation ya aussi des gens qui ont servi
de lanceurs d'alertés qu'on a jamais
écoutés absolue requise ariza même toi
ou tu commences à parler pas mal
notamment de ppda et tout ça m'est été
la première à dire les choses que
j'avais depuis 15 ans et en parle
aujourd'hui
c'est ce que je disais aujourd'hui je le
disais il ya 15 ans mon père nous
pourrons j'aurais jamais porté plainte
pour un truc comme ça si je me situe à
l'époque je me tais aujourd'hui mais ce
que je dis aujourd'hui je le disais à
l'époque ah bon mais oui personne ne
m'écoutait mais tout le monde me disait
ah bon mais tout le monde le disait à
l'époque - failles et ça on peut le dire
devant une caméra et y
avait un procès immédiatement mais tout
le monde le disait